mommy  why do we have to open our presents on  christmas eve  why not christmas day like everybody  else  you know at school you do tenses yeah  it's past  the present future right  well here  there is only one tense  there is no future  past and the present to the same thing  daddy told harry it's books father  christmas does queens and kings the day  before everybody else  it's like we get the best presents it's  true he still believes it though what  but actually that was my little  fabrication i believe mommy  daddy did confirm it though oh if daddy  confirmed it then it must be true yes of  course it is  you two are both gonna get cold for  christmas  can we go to the house where you used to  live  it's boarded up  it's dangerous apparently  they said  it's dangerous you know  there's voices like doors closing did  granny order that  man the others are waiting  [Music]  you